any flavors that's like a 1,500 square
miles for cheerio needle in a haystack
welcome to Grandma with me joshing
tonight and today a storm is brewing we
have sound carefully and his shining
would leave from the stars of a drift
now we're gonna play a game with you a
really catchy one called complete the
song lyric okay and then I'm gonna be so
and there rain and storm themed songs
umbrella that is one of them plot twists
and you have to buzz in and compete
against each other your buzz word is
Anchors Away and yours is abandon ship
okay purple rain by Prince I never meant
to cause you any sorrow I never meant to
cause you any pain dot dot dot
Purple Rain Anchors Away purple oh do
you have to say he was okay it's raining
man by the weather girls or Jerry honey
well depending on when you were born
right okay honey when she's doing the
word count the aerobics yeah yeah the
greatest oh my god okay it's a classic
okay so humidity is rising the paramitas
getting low according to wall sauce oh
sorry according to all sources the
streets a place to go Chris tonight for
the first time
it's gonna stop yeah
Malaysia I turn this into a music
honestly because wow
Jerry Jerry well yeah what's your back
Gary I was so starstruck oh she was my
favorite
really yeah umbrella by Rihanna now that
it's raining more than ever know she
breaks it down into Ella okay okay this
is a classic singing the rain by Gene
Kelly I'm singing in the rain just
singing the rain
dot dot dot buzz-buzz feeling oh I'm
happy again yes yeah you got it babe
yeah that was it that's true I think
that yeah yeah Tootie
I sense a duo coming on at some stage
we're gonna write our own yeah rain
musical and you can collaborate with
Geri Halliwell yeah it's called the rain
train around the world is fine
I'm not really new